la dernière page de ce journal sera
consacrée au cinéma africain jean
jacques dufour et alain du bas ont
rencontré le réalisateur idrissa
ouédraogo qui en est en quelque sorte le
porte drapeau pour eux qu'ils nous
proposent à partir d'aujourd'hui son
dernier film samba traoré la star la
voilà chez elle au burkina faso pendant
le festival de ouaga idrissa tourner un
court-métrage l'histoire d'un peul qui
arrivent dans la capitale le peul n'ai
pas peur c'est un jeune comédien
burkinabè
mais je crois que c'est normal parce que
sinon on n'aura jamais aucun prix
primé à cannes à carthage à berlin
idrissa n'espérait rien à ouaga puisque
son film samba traoré était projeté hors
compétition
entrée gratuite pour les festivaliers 5
francs 50 pour les autres pas cher pour
voir une belle histoire d'amour gâchée
par l'argent le héros est pourtant
généreux mais voilà le pognon provient
d'un casse et ça complique tout
chifflet fait qu'appuyer rôle est ce que
vous êtes fier quand il obtient des prix
à l'étranger
trop fier parce que à ce moment on parle
des dix cerveaux de l'envoyer on parle
de ses acteurs et sud l'acteur 2 0
je suis content et 10 à 11 euros et pour
ses prix c'est pour l'en pays burkina
faso paris 2-0 d'euros pour le team
battle ya beaucoup qui servent
aujourd'hui à lui connaître au burkina
l'un des pays les plus pauvres du monde
on partage avec fierté son succès un
succès qui ne lui monte pas la tête
il pense qu'il a encore beaucoup de
choses à apprendre on considérait encore
comme un étudiant je pensais que je fais
encore de beaucoup d'humilité ça non
c'est la réalité c'est
on n'a pas les moyens de nos rêves donc
ils voient les six mois est conscient
que ce n'est que par cela qu'on arrivera
à ces moyens-là raconter sans effets de
style sans batterie est un beau film
simple et limpide